foreign
[Music]
how did this come about
so seven or eight years ago uh our
youngest son went to college and I
didn't have much to do
so I thought well we have a few stories
to tell so why don't we try documentary
films and that's literally how this
started I met my producing partner
through his wife I said hey Kyle's a
senior at Drexel maybe we should film
that year and just see what happens and
today you saw what happened so so Katie
what how did the conversate the first
conversation go with the two of you with
regards to what film were going away
what are the goals here what were the
initial goals at the very very beginning
well there's an there's another beat in
between sort of what Jen is talking
about so there was a diff there's many
beats to the story of this film so there
was another team that was that filmed
Kyle's last year at Drexel and they did
about a 40-minute film that kind of
focused you know on inner cutting that
year with archival footage so it was and
it was a lovely short film Jen
had that and felt that there was still
something that was not complete to the
story but she wasn't necessarily sure
what that was so we started meeting at
that point I had seen that film I had
seen other of the archival footage and I
was really I mean I was transfixed by
that archival footage I was a mom of two
you know young medium age kids at the
time and it was like hit me like a ton
of bricks in the heart this idea of you
know being in this room having this
intentionality with your kids this it
was I mean I really had never seen
footage like that before
um so we met and I felt really strongly
at that point that there was kind of a
third leg of the stool that was missing
which was incorporating the family and
their stories which they hadn't really
told until that point so I took a little
convincing to get her to agree that like
they were gonna you know lend themselves
to the film because of course everybody
felt that you know this essentially is
Kyle's story but the the only way we
were going to get to Kyle sort of as the
nucleus was to give a little space to
the to the rest of the group so
um we worked for a long time on that and
then at a certain point
Dan came in to help us with some
structure and some upgrading sort of and
and extraordinary animation that is in
the film Dan took the lead on that
take it away Dan uh yeah oh did I just
turn my mic off I think I did there we
go
um yeah I mean I came in there was sort
of a version of the film and uh a kind
of restructured it and did some
additional interviews really trying to
look at
um
everybody is an individual character
that had an arc and how can we kind of
get a satisfying storyline for each of
them
um and just treating like kind of coming
in blind and not knowing
you know the long history that had gone
on with the previous teams and
iterations and just said like how do we
make this into a film that people will
connect with
um and that's and so we kind of recut it
and I did new animation and all that
stuff so that's what it is Kyle the
question is
how did you feel about all this I mean
about about having
the cameras around all the time and
being interviewed and talking about
about your your life that's a great
question Scott uh you know it's an
interesting process I mean it's it's a
one it's sort of a once in a lifetime
opportunity to sort of have this moment
to really tell your story about growing
up as a kid and everything that you went
through and I really took the film as
sort of a video diary like if you had
like the like a imagine if you had like
a video diary and you're like okay this
is it I'm gonna tell my story I'm gonna
do it now in this moment it was just
sort of like you know I'm gonna tell the
truth this is what happened this is my
story and I just took that moment and um
I think it was really great yeah yeah
well it is thanks guys so so Jennifer I
want to ask you like when you're
watching this movie
your interviews you are so passionate
you are so you you're clear on what it
is you want this film to be was that
evident from the very beginning or did
you kind of figure it out
as the movie was sort of being being
produced
you know it's it's interesting I started
my film coma film company with this film
so I feel like I kind of grew up as a
producer while we were doing the film I
learned a ton at every iteration every
round of notes uh you know that kind of
thing but I think the thing that was
most important to us was making sure
that we kept Kyle's voice so you know
how often do you get a person like Kyle
to narrate their own story as well so
that's what Katie worked with me on
that's what Kate Dan worked with me on
was making sure yes we need the family
we need other voices but we really have
to make sure we keep Kyle's voice okay
so so talk more about that if you could
uh about you know that the conversations
that you had to to make sure that Kyle's
voice was front and center even though
you were bringing all this balance in
with uh with it being informational and
of course being personal with the family
but about being steadfast with what
Jennifer wanted
yeah there's a lot you know as you can
see from from the cut you saw I mean
there are a lot of interviews with Kyle
you like when you talk about this video
diary sensibility like we talked to Kyle
a lot and and it was it would be because
you would you know you would do these
interviews and then you know you would
re-watch them or listen to them and see
like oh there's a little Wormhole we
could go down here we could go deeper
here and you know you can only put
through people through so much right you
work you do an interview for an hour I
mean who knows how much is there and I
think
um
it's this sense of like continuing to go
back to the spine of like what feels
true to him I mean there's these
touchstones about like it taking a long
time to get through this stuff that was
you know that was really big for me that
that that the statements around like his
sensibility here one I'll just finish
this sensibility of what he brought to
Fashion in terms of like that that
always you know and it was sometimes
harder for you to put that into words
but just that sense of like this was a
gift to me in this other world right so
you could I feel like and I'm sure Dan
feels the same you kind of pick four or
five of these really truthful statements
from Kyle and then you kind of try to
line up the structure around like these
are what was true to him yeah that's a
really great point I just want to riff
off of that really quick and you know
sort of how have you autism now is you
know it's not so it's not my main world
it's a world that's a part of my past
but one of the gifts what of it is sort
of my unique way that I sort of Channel
or transcend into a space where I can
think about fashion and uh it just it's
it's come it's came naturally from that
world and it's something that I use in
my everyday life but it's something that
I always say I always say it's like you
know I have a toy box that I keep in a
shelf in the closet I can take down that
toy box and I can open it up and I can
reminisce reminisce and you know play
with the toys in there and then when I'm
done I can you know put the toys away I
can close the lid in the Box I can put
the lid back in the closet and then I
can close the closet door and you know I
think that's what he was referencing was
there is this special unique
thing that I just inherited from my
childhood that you know I use my world
of imagination I wrote I use the world
of imagination that autism gave me and
I'm always thankful for that uh you know
when it comes to the prep and the
research especially the research I mean
Jennifer you lived it you've did a whole
lot of research over the years but Dan
like what kind of research and prep did
you and Katie do because you know you
this was this was new for you so what
kind of prep and research did you do and
what were some of the things that you
discovered
along the way
um well I
I did a fairly Deep dive into into what
the treatments were like in uh you know
at the time that Kyle got on the sunrise
program and
you know we found this that there's a
clip from the the sunrise movie there
was a the feature film of the fiction
the scripted film kind of about the
story of the kid that Sunrise was based
on and it's it's very dated and strange
but it was kind of fascinating to see
that
um but kind of just you know I was
fascinated because I didn't know
anything about this world just to find
out
um how different those two approaches
were
um and and one of the things that I
really wanted to
or I think one of the things that I did
when I came on was was bring in sort of
voices that were sort of outside of the
sunrise World
um like Andrew Sheehan the the
um therapist who had worked in the
program but then left it and and now
kind of works outside of it and was able
to kind of give a perspective of like
well it's a great program for some in
some ways and it works for some kids but
you know these are some of the downsides
of it and so I wanted to make sure that
we had kind of a balance
um
been talking about the different
approaches
it looked like you were going to say
something Kyle
um well I mean I I think you know all
the I think gambling some great points
about you know what the treatments
options were and I think my mom could
really speak to that speak to that in
terms of you know she found the sunrise
program through a friend at a Christmas
party I guess it was completely random
and I think she could speak more on that
but
um it really was at the time there
really wasn't a lie you know between
1993 to 2004 when autism really was
becoming mainstream there just wasn't a
lot of options it there just or wasn't
really talked about so
um
you know with the story we we always say
we we hope this this is one story about
autism it's not the story but we uh but
we hope it brings hope to your story and
so for us I think that's what's really
important well that that's the other
thing Jennifer is hey this is more than
just about autism this is a this is
going to help a lot of people I think uh
this is about bigger issues uh was that
something that was conscious for all of
you as you were making the film or did
you like just make the film and and then
look back and go actually wow this
really does impact a lot of things well
I think Kyle made the point which is the
awareness of just not even just autism
but mental health today is a completely
different space than when we started the
film so really we started the film
because we thought all right a lot of
people have said you have to tell your
story and I just couldn't figure out
what was the right medium to use so like
I said when documentary films came along
I thought all right we could do it that
way it took us seven years to get it to
a point where I felt like this is the
story this is the truth This is Our
Truth as Kyle said it's just one story
but you know the the reality is we did a
sunrise program so I can't apologize for
that
um but it but it also there was I think
as Dan and Katie pointed out there were
definitely flaws with the program as
well so we wanted to make sure we could
keep it as balanced as possible by being
but still be true to the story
Kyle while you were being interviewed
the process of of your interviews was
there a part that was harder for you to
talk about
that's a great question I think for me I
think
uh when it comes to talking about family
I think you know if anyone wants to talk
about their family I think it's you know
immediate Water Works Etc I mean it's
it's something so personal and so close
so I think you know always being asked
questions about family I think it's just
always a plate number one
um and it's also was one thing that I
love to talk about because I mean who
doesn't like talking about their family
and where they're from and uh and so but
I think for me
um I really took every question I was
every question that I was asked and
really
came up with a really thoughtful uh and
really a responsive State true to who I
was at my values and so that's how I led
with the film
so you I during my course you know
moderate these types of conversations
with filmmakers especially documentary
filmmakers so many of them talk about
how they started the movie with this
goal in mind and then they're making the
film they're doing their interviews and
their goals change they maybe somebody
says something and they go wait that's
our movie so did your goals Katie change
throughout the course of the filmmaking
process
you know this was a really collaborative
process I mean when I discuss how
there's the other team that started at
Drexel and then you know my involvement
dance involvement and the collaboration
with the family is like a constant
dialogue about what is this film like
because even when we say like it's our
truth you know it is a it's it is their
truth but my God there's so many ways to
you know there's so many Avenues to get
to truth and how do you bring an
audience along the path of that truth in
a way that's going to be effective right
so I mean we were just
I don't know that there were moments
that radically changed I mean I do think
that we had a lot of conversations about
how much background do you need about
the the what the autism landscape was at
that time I would say like we definitely
dialed that way up and way down in
different iterations you know there was
different iterations around the
involvement of the of the siblings I
mean which now it's like you're always
turning up and down these dials I don't
know that we had something in this
process and there's also the question of
like when do you end the film right
Kyle's this is not a historical figure
we are you know uh and and so it's
really hard to figure out like when is
the right moment to sort of say like Hey
we're done let's turn off the camera so
I think those were the questions for us
on this rather than like wow we're
making this 180 degree turn
well and I don't know if you noticed but
we didn't have a lot in there about the
middle years so like puberty and things
like that you know we started down that
road
um but you know really I think fashion
was the thing and so building that
thread to where Kyle was a little guy in
Cinderella dress-ups through Cinderella
to then fashion school and then to being
a fashion designer it just became more
of an important thread than touching on
every single aspect of his growing up so
I I think we there were like Katie said
there were moments we looked at it and
we're like all right that has to go
because we just can't build that out the
way it's gonna it's gonna be useful to
the story
so I would love to open this up to the
audience if anybody has questions uh and
before I do that hold that thought let's
want to ask one question this is going
to get a little existential
but yeah since you've sat through
screenings you've watched a film
yourself Kyle
was there something that you discovered
about yourself watching a movie about
you
uh that's a really good question
um and I think what's interesting I
think every time you watch a film I
think you always see something new it's
like whenever I watch schitt's Creek
shit's creek for like this 6 000 times
because it's so amazing I'm always like
oh my God you know I just discovered
that joke here and there and so I think
you find little things and I think uh
you know I just think that's such a fun
process but I think in terms of uh you
know learning about yourself I think you
know I think you always learn uh
what you can and can't handle and I
think you know uh from doing the Q and
A's to doing interviews to doing you
know just going out and talking about
this film you really learn about
yourself and how independent you can be
and what you can do and uh you know even
you know I say in the program you know
uh where I stand the film uh you know uh
starting out having conversations and
dialogue with people and strangers and
people I didn't know was like
Arachnophobia and then in college I was
the person that was like don't talk to
me I'm gonna have a conversation with
you and I'm going to procrastinate so it
was from point A to point B and so I
think uh this is just uh I think uh
Kaleidoscope of that journey in a way
wow that's a great answer and where was
that question I think that was yours oh
right here you yeah go ahead nice and
Loud please
[Music]
voice
did you start at the beginning thinking
okay I'm gonna make a film or
did you end up filming so much you know
that's it seems like that would be the
case because there was so much footage
but the big big part of the sunrise
program was filming your volunteers and
people that worked with Kyle so that we
could constantly record what was
happening how was he doing how is he
reacting to this what were the isms he
was involved with at the time so that we
could always be adjusting the program
and how we were working with him so
that's really what the the all that
footage was about how much footage did
you have in the end geez what do you
think I mean 500 hundreds of hours in
all various I literally took a gigantic
box of tapes of every shape and size
dropped it at my producer friend's feet
and said here you go I don't know what
you do with this but what's funny too is
I mean they were not intending to make a
documentary of any of that so you'd have
a tape in there and you'd be like oh
this is really interesting and then
you'd have like you know a Gossip Girl
recorded over that okay right I mean
it'd all be like right in the same stuff
that's where you saw some of the footage
from Germany or the kids playing in the
in the basement or you know footage of
my daughter filmed of Jake and she so
you know that was all mixed in
yeah I used to get so mad when my
parents tape start taped over my Star
Trek episodes uh who else has a question
uh yes you and the glasses
sure personally I want to say how long
away I am
um I'd be as a fellow fellow fashion
designer
how much you were able to accomplished
[Music]
of that and how
and how you got it being all about the
fashion show as the end and end-all be
off and I love that you continued it
through to this
move
the chapter
if you're as an adult living in the
world and having started in a room and
then you kind of were in New York City
one of the biggest cities in the world
menu for
you for that not an easy growth
and
to stay creative so thank you Matt I
appreciate it
um yeah you know I think for me uh the
whole process of the collection and
doing the whole thing I think what's so
cool is I think
uh the film kind of really shows up what
lined up naturally I mean looking one
thing's going back to some of the
previous questions in terms of do you
see anything that was lining up really
is uh you know the tribe that Cinderella
had got repeated in real life I mean I
mean Sally and that you know all my
professors and everyone it was like
it was almost like a microcosm version
of Cinderella brought into 3D and so I
just happened to be Cinderella at the
time and so
um I just thought that was a you know
just a great point that was brought
through and and it was so true and it
was just so natural on the way that
happened what kind of uh reaction have
you gotten from people who've seen the
film uh maybe maybe at a like a a q a
conversation where
you there was a reaction that really
stood out to you you know like was there
something special that was said at one
of these screenings that like really
meant a lot to you
yeah that's a great question uh for me I
did a screening at my alma mater at
Drexel and we had a student who was on
the Spectrum and uh she really connected
with a lot of the points in the film
that really connected with her own life
and it really
created a moment in the Q a that was
special I think for everyone in the
audience and the entire room it really
brought everyone together in this one
moment and it was it was pretty
spectacular I would say that's probably
the number one highlight that would be
pretty high
uh and also uh you know what uh react
you got a question okay
[Music]
were you wearing a hearing aid at one
seat and if you ever depend on sign or
were you always just speak
that's a great question
um I uh I was a little bit hard of
hearing but uh it was mostly from ear
infections and so over the years I had
many operations uh that allowed it to be
cleared up but
um so I uh the need for sign wasn't
um
specifically needed uh but I do think
sign language is a really incredible art
form and I think uh it's a really beef
language uh that needs to be celebrated
in its own right
yeah but thank you I appreciate that
and and Jennifer is there anything else
that you hope people take away from Let
Me Be Me
[Music]
this young man's question is exactly it
that everyone that we've from the people
who've come and spoken to me after the
film it's a remarkable how people will
say well I you know a older man who's a
father of children would say I really
resonated with your husband's story
siblings of a kids who have special
needs in some way or a form would say I
really resonated with your daughter and
your son Jake you know Moms come up to
me last night someone came up to me and
had really exactly the same story same
child same almost the same isms same age
so
that connection is really what I feel is
most powerful about the film is helping
people as Kyle said just a few minutes
ago in some way connect seeing our story
just this one story helping you connect
to your story and I hope I hope it helps
you find Hope in your story because
there's hope in everyone's story Kyle
you get the last word
you know I think you know I think what's
special about Let Me Be me is I think
anyone can watch it and see something
special and uh you know like my mom just
said really bring hope to their own
story and I think you know I think hope
is super powerful and I think it's great
I think we need more of it
for sure
so ladies and gentlemen
now that you have seen Let Me Be Me
spread the word about it and how do you
spread the word obviously you know go on
social media so go on Facebook go on
Instagram go on well maybe don't go on
Twitter
spread the word and I just have to say
to my my friends here from Philadelphia
which is where I was born give my
regards to South Street thank you
everyone for being here at film
independent thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign